فرق الانقاظ الان وطواقم الاص طواقم
الاسعاف الدفاع المدني هنا في هذا
المكان سيطروا على الحريق في منزل عائله
جوش بالنصيرات هذا المنزل هو غير مخلى من
السكان بداخل هذا المنزل ما يزيد عن 20
شخص كما تحدث لنا احد جيران هذا المنزل 18
شخصا داخل البدروم واثنين او ثلا ثلاثه
اشخاص كانوا في المنزل الذي تم قصفه من
قبل المقاتلات الحربيه بحسب روايه احد
جيران هذا المنزل يقول بان اطفال ونساء هم
من بداخل هذا
المنزل لم يتم اخلائه حتى اللحظه ما تم
انتشاله من الاصابات هم من جيران هذا
المنزل
المستهدف اكثر من ثلاثه
صواريخ وهي
عباره عن قنابل شديده
التدمير ضربت هذا المنزل سوته بالارض عده
طوابق تم تسويه هذا المنزل بالارض تدميره
بشكل كامل في عين كامله يا عم
بتكون كبيره جدا في هذا المكان وهذا
المنزل المستهدف والذي دمرته المقاتلات
الحربيه هنا الماء ك شا هذا المكان ه هنا
النيران اطلع والله اطلع اشتعلت في منطقه
اخرى من هذا المنزل المستهدف يتم الان
انتشال عدد من الشهداء بعد ان كنا فجر هذا
اليوم في هذا
المنزليه وتحدثنا عن وجود اعداد تحت انقاض
هذا
المنزل رحمه الله عليك غط عليه غط عليه
خلص حرام حطوا وجوهها
لفوا
لفوا هذا هو منزل عائله قواش هذا المنزل
الذي دمرته المقاتلات الحربيه فجر هذا
اليوم ورصدت قناه الجزيره لحظه يعني
الاستهداف والدمار الكبير والحريق الهائل
الذي كان في هذا المنزل في هذا الصباح
الباكر توجهت فرق الانقاذ
لانتشال المصابين
او العالقين تحت هذا
الركام هذه هي الحفره الكبيره
التي نتجت
عن قصف المقاتلات الحربيه
لمنزل عائله
جووش هذا هو الدمار
الكبير في هذا
المنزل يعني نحن
على ركام هذا
المنزل المستهدف منزل عائله جوش بالنصيرات
فرق الانقاظ الان تعثر على
احد
الشهداء يعني شهيد جديد الان يتم انتشاله
من قبل فرق الانقاذ وطواقم الدفاع المدني
ينتشرون الان احد الشهداء من تحت ركام
منزل عائله جوش والذي قصفته المقاتلات
الحربيه فجر هذا
اليوم